finishing the course led to personal
recognition and opened the door for even
more artificial intelligence projects
and it came with a significant pay raise
money I had
no Steve Jobs once said the only way to
do something great is to love what you
do and if you haven't found it yet keep
looking never settle
so after taking the course from Simply
land
I discovered my passion hi my name is
D'Angelo and I reside in Richmond
Washington I completed simply learns
artificial intelligence master's program
so as long as I can remember I've been
fascinated by it and interested in
Cutting Edge technology even though I
was confident in my field I was eager to
broaden my knowledge and meet the
evolving need for my employer and others
like them after much research I decided
to use simply learn to enhance my
knowledge simply learns flexible
learning strategy allowed me to balance
out school with a full-time job and
valid applications I'm glad I stuck with
it because finishing the course led to
personal recognition and opened the door
for even more artificial intelligence
projects and it came with a significant
pay raise money ahead by not settling I
could find the job that I generally
enjoy doing in addition I've been able
to put my acquired knowledge to Great
use as a volunteer for the first Global
organization that helps kids through
constructive machines and robots the
experience has been very enjoyable and
very rewarding if you want to succeed in
Corporate America you have to constantly
learn new skills and sharpen the ones
that you already have when I hear people
talking about one of their learning
skills I mean it's a no-brainer simply
land
I hope to be a CEO of my own software
company one day also I love sharing what
I've learned with others AI is such a
fascinating area of study and practice I
believe more people should be trained to
work in this field because it's one of
several new emerging Technologies
leading the charge in the fourth
industrial industry
if you're driven to accomplish something
don't be afraid to die right here
getting started is just half the battle
and once you do you'll be glad you did
you can do anything you set your mind to
so never stop dreaming and never stop
achieving remember there's always room
for growth don't see yourself any less
than what you see other people be
capable of because if they can do it
I can do it
I know you can do it